my gears H have been grinded and that's
the taxal gears this whole idea of tax
deductions and we walk through this in
financial pie University but I'm like
how bad are you at math that you think
sending $10,000 to your mortgage lender
in interest is better than sending
$2,000 to the
IRS that's what you're doing you're
stepping over a dollar to pick up a
quarter and thinking that you're winning
and the mortgage companies love this
they're like great send us more interest
in instead of the IRS we're way better
than the IRS that's what you're doing
and by the way almost nobody itemizes on
their taxes anymore everyone takes the
standard deduction which means you don't
get to deduct your mortgage interest T
so almost nobody's doing this so This
theoretical idea that you're doing it
for the tax deductions is wildly
illogical